what about the Comedy Central uh hey
could you pull up Andrew Soltis video
for about Comedy Central please on his
Instagram I love this [ __ ]
Schulz call me on the way over there he
did yeah how's he doing good yeah yeah
he's always good huh yeah he's got a
good disposition yes he does God lucky
bastard he central got fired last week
oh I heard like every executive central
got fired last week that's crazy man
yeah I mean we're talking about
yesterday they have passed on so many I
mean I like yeah and I never understood
like why they wouldn't just give people
the benefit meaning sign people to like
a three-year deal and go just come up
with a show for yourself yeah and you
can they go alright we'll shoot it and
then they're gonna do another one do
another one do another one like just if
your I have a theory that that they
didn't ever really like the shows that
were hits for them like yeah they didn't
like South Park they just found crass
Tosh they didn't like yeah it's just
Freddie what they call Freddie yeah like
off what is this junk yeah that's what's
paying your salary yes that's the [ __ ]
that keeps like review and and Nathan
for you don't make money
Tosh [ __ ] makes money Chappelle show
makes money they thought they'd they I
think they didn't like the they didn't
like the tone it's just not like
sophisticated and buttoned up so it
wasn't a daily show was kind of created
in-house Doug Herzog who was the
president was like we should do like a
Sports Center for the news
right so that and and they love John and
that's a big moneymaker and and Colbert
was a [ __ ] great show to like both
very good shows and very profitable for
them and then but they're now they had
all the people there had nothing to do
with them so they want to make sort of
more sad city and they want to make
whitey Keppler whatever that show was
yeah they picked up some it's like what
is this it made a lot of stuff that I
felt like was ain't like very leftist
you know they didn't stay in the middle
of the road at all well they are not in
the middle of the people that work there
are not middle of road so that's what
I'm saying they think Tosh is Friday and
Chappelle shows kind of Freddie and and
South Park's kind of Freddie like they
don't crazy yeah I just and that that
you would I don't know I just it makes
me mad cuz I'm only in there are so many
times and pitch them so many things I
spent a year developing this really
great project with them but I think I'm
probably standing up releasing on
YouTube you know it just burns me up
sometimes Manson yeah I did a couple
piles Mormon and they didn't pick him up
and I was always like you don't want to
just pick it up just cuz of Chappelle
show just maybe just me I don't know
[ __ ] maybe I maybe I maybe I'm good
luck or something
I am oh I always do well like I did an
hour on their network get rated really
well yeah they just I I don't I think
certain people they just don't they like
who they like and they don't like who
they don't like
yeah and there's nothing you can do
about it well they always think if girl
wants to sleep with you or not and I'm
you can't be like don't you look at this
tie it does I don't care
i-i've already decided right and they
make their mind up they like
sophisticated alternative Williamsburg
II Silver Lake II that's their that's
their the people who works there's
personality evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one
ah